[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back to off-the-record
a we talked about whatever we want my
brain farted for a second then we have
[Music]
today's videos brought to you by a
barbell / j thank you
release these new gloves go check it out
at the bar ball shop bar ball brigade do
you have them in black and white another
with no no yes just sad why just I
didn't do it that hard is that comfy huh
I've been great just like flying around
traveling a lot just trying to get my
sleep schedule back on track you know
what the fast-food works yeah what the
hell was that all about the fast food
award it was hosted by you and
apparently David too but the poster is
just you and then they got love that the
ball paint you can barely see his eyes
yeah it's a blatant disrespect we have
this guy from wildin out and some guy
that looks like a relative writer site
director you know what happened is the
poster probably probably you and David
Davis laid down and they're like just
keep covering that guy with balls go
don't stop well you know what there was
somebody commented that in the in the in
the comments and they're like oh how
come how come no David in the poster oh
and no but maybe it's a metaphor cuz on
send foods we have this like running gag
where it's like people recognize me and
they don't care about David yeah and
then you know and kids will come up to
us and they always say David you're
famous to take a picture and they they
do this whole bit like I'm gonna ignore
Tim and take pictures with David so that
we give him some shine on the episode oh
but what they don't get is that we cut
all that anyways because the joke is
that they only come up to me so I said
wait so then David gets annoyed because
the kids come up to David they're like
hey man don't worry about your famous -
David's like it's a it's a joke oh dude
we don't care it's just for the bees is
the marketing department where is the
marketing department aware of this Joe
what you want to know some drama with
the fast food award yeah yes drama is
the best [ __ ] in the world so so just
like real quick like so 30s was like
okay yeah let's do these fast food
awards right so they called him the fast
these they had me and David hosted
that's why we're in New York would
you're hosting like a quick little fun
it's like an hour long award show was
like soup it little silly stuff like oh
we had the best chicken sandwich of the
year they had a little memorial memoriam
where they call those oh yeah for like
the talked about menu party yeah for all
like the menu of your menu items that
like are no longer with us she liked
that just funny I'm cute what was the
best chicken sandwich of the year wait
you're interrupting him for another
story I want to hear the drama star what
I see him the goal is go and then go
right yeah so what those didn't realize
is there is this guy um who who's like a
writer for The Simpsons so he has like a
like a like his own following but he
does a thing in his car where he does
fast-food awards and I guess he takes
his fast-food really seriously and so he
was like what the [ __ ] bill is ripped
off my dog and all he is like all his
like followers are in throws his
comments like well that's messed up that
you would that you would take his idea
we're just raiding and giving awards to
fast food that sounds like such a basic
idea that's what I'm saying but but his
father was like well that's pretty
messed up that you would just take his
that we take our fast food awards very
seriously like I get that you would be
irritated when you feel like you know
you have the only one and then like a
bigger company comes it's like what
we're gonna do you're right your idea
but at the same time it's like giving
awards to things isn't you like a
concept you can copyright giving a worse
the things that you didn't make yeah you
don't own any of that like did the SAG
Awards copy like steal account
the awards idea or you know that's silly
you know this will probably backfire
against me in my career but I don't get
well I don't get why to have the SAG
Awards it isn't the SAG Awards supposed
to be more of like you know the people
vote right I don't think so man I think
that's the People's Choice waggons
literally the people in SAG are voting
on it
but everyone's in SAG is also in
everyone in the Oscars all since act so
I'm like but the Oscars is a very
specific academy of people without true
right and then SAG is like everybody
there we see the Hart's make some
people's vote of the actors auditors
yeah yeah everybody in the Union can
vote are you saying I'm saying yeah yeah
I don't never want to be you get the
screeners said he said you know said
yeah I get the screeners yeah that's my
man why would you want to be saying it's
just on the big projects never mind that
well and and when you're set you know
it's like it's like a union you get
benefits I rather be a sweatshop worker
I'm Asian that's it
sweatshop also I have health insurance
in Sag for the first time of my life
they give you health insurer it's like
that's just so Luke that sounds better
better some say it's a union Joe if you
were in a sweatshop would you be the guy
in there going we can't uni guys don't
do this to the manager that would be me
why would you guys want to get paid more
what's wrong with you health care pay
out of your own pocket [ __ ] I never had
health care and so like past couple
years so what happened to the guy was
did you guys like oh shut up oh I mean I
mean thorough this was just kind of like
I don't know how they handled it I think
we're like Oh more booze Oh what they
did is they stopped referring it to it
as the first ever fast-food award
because that's what they were doing huh
dude after two days nobody's gonna
remember exactly no one [ __ ] kidding
people are gonna marinate on this [ __ ]
for like a month later like I can't
believe they stole this format from you
yeah people that feels were like home
man oh it's going down right now an hour
on Twitter like people that people ever
said I'm look like no one give a [ __ ]
ten people it's really not a big deal so
how did they how do they determine how
do they protect the votes from from
outside undue influence it's it's I
think the votes from for the fastest
throws show is uh just the Thrillist
food experts and whoever was ever out
but they obviously have they have to
deliberate somewhere then they have to
cast their ballots and then those what
are those ballots go well how do they
protect it from people finding out was a
guy with the suitcase and then he has
the handcuff to it and nobody like has
to sleep with it his wife can't see it
it's like a double key submarine
situation what should should put my god
like a bag of food though thinking like
it's in a McDonald's bag or something
no that's the decoy okay got it yeah
yeah I wonder how serious the committee
takes their job great like they're
deciding who to [ __ ] put in for the
next president it's funny because when
they gave the awards away you know there
was a couple of people to accept the
awards were like guys that were from the
executive office of these like fast food
places you know and I think the guy from
White Castle was so honored he gave like
a nice speech and they're my friends
RINO crinkle-cut fries we do nachos and
the same establishment
you know respect they'll talk to a
chicken their chicken tacos I know
they're so good hey sir was there
anybody that one that you like what the
[ __ ] um oh yeah yeah have you ever heard
of Col ders yeah I've never heard of
Culver's oh is that so it's a burger
place but it's more um I guess they're
there in Arizona they were in the middle
maybe like a Hardee's called Junior
situation no it's just if they're their
own [ __ ] and it's called kober's and
they won the burger of the year yeah
Greg they have some butter burger that
one off one of the [ __ ] voter that's
what it was maybe good cuz if we left up
to California people and just be in and
out every year well yeah
be a boring ceremony where are you from
huh where are you from from these girls
hey I'm a California person that doesn't
want in and out I like havin burger
which is technically California burger
is that considered fast-food to have it
yeah I like washable man I don't even
know what fast food I'm Shake Shack baby
and but it's not really fast because I
thought fast food means you can leave it
in your car for three days in the next
day it's still perfectly same yeah yeah
I ought to do that if there was a
fallout you could that food is gonna
last you can eat it today that's that's
that's fast but you've really sure but
in and out is also like never frozen
yeah that's why you can't in like two
hours I taste it and it's cost
I think fast casual I think the
difference is in I mean a fast food is
the food's already prepped and it's like
left there my damn Wendy's also is never
frozen
oh yeah square burgers too that makes me
feel weird as of three years ago I think
yeah cuz I don't I think that's a new
thing
ah I miss that old man you guys remember
that old man yeah Wendy's birthday oh
yeah the Wendy's man he died recent like
couple years ago enough years ago he'll
be like oh [ __ ] yeah Wendy's guy I grew
up on this fall you know he ate Wendy's
- he looks like he made all the burgers
he looks like a human teddy bear yeah he
looks cute yeah adorable he also looks
like the cat from the Carson show who
did Star Search and those oh yeah looks
a dead ringer dead [ __ ] ringer
searching for the stars
oh my god Star Search oh yeah as far as
I can't [ __ ] read that's that's
American Idol before
they would go to the malls and stuff
that you had auditions when I was a
talent show
when I was like a horny 11 year old I
used to try to watch that to look at
chicks Star Search yeah glitter gallons
and [ __ ] you know yeah that was Baywatch
oh yeah Baywatch Rochelle watch Baywatch
wasn't always on married with children
kill me with spring oh my god I would
take that [ __ ] hoping that a/c will pop
out where Christina Applegate and her
[ __ ] flock of friends would come out
so I could pause that [ __ ] and
jack off to it because they wouldn't
wear bras and they it was awesome I
would fast-forward during all any time I
my keys at the shoe store my because
that [ __ ] those things were so funny
it's and those jokes were so [ __ ] up
like you can't even do that [ __ ] today I
know he's always got some really fat
lady that comes in and she's like loving
and he has to put on the shoe but
there's also like always hot girls that
come in and he misses it cuz he was
sleeping and then they leave one of my
favorite episodes of him we were with it
with it with a customer so like he had
already got in trouble for like making
fat jokes at 4:04 what another one of
the customers so he was like he was in
like he was in trouble you know I'm
saying so of his boss like you cannot
have another one of these situations you
have to be nice to all your customers so
he's like alright so he's like helping
this lady with her her shoe and she has
this huge [ __ ] like you know just
like this is a sweaty gross foot she's
like don't I have the cutest toes I'm
just a size two aren't they so cute
and he's like and he's like so I think
they closed about him he's sweating
dripping sweat he's like yeah super cute
for sausages sausages sausages and he's
like oh [ __ ] I messed up because that
was the joke is he kept roasting up and
they never want to buy anything in a
league but when you're being a horny kid
it's not the best scenes
it's neither get back to the applegate
see what's what's wrong with those jokes
now we got a change of now cuz it's mean
who doesn't mean - sausage feet wasn't
it funny well I think cuz they're
singling out one type of body type so
he's called the other one like a skinny
person all you got twig feet it would
have been balanced out I guess but I
think just you don't want to make fun of
people anymore it's all about
inclusivity now well yeah but roasts are
more popular than ever yeah that's true
yeah so I think there's nothing there's
both happening yeah like when you watch
like they're in on it oh yeah yeah did
it's fun yeah I guess like you're saying
like the other person on the other end
is not in on it
yeah but they are in like right if it's
a sweet people know they're funny just
like how skinny people know they're
funny everyone else are smart but also
like if you look at it like it's a
scripted show then the person in the
scene is enormous in on the joke yeah
but the people that are watching it are
they're like hey you're picking on so
when you roast people now you don't
really roast them on their appearance a
race or weight or whatever you can if
they're they're like saying this is my
roast about me well the best thing is
like you know for that show even it's
like hey casting call morbidly obese
woman with bad feet yeah then you know
and then ladies like here's my big break
he picks up the phone and she's like I
got it the people actually want to be on
the show sure which is time like you
saying that she's consenting the joke
yeah well then but the argument of that
would be like there is no other rules
for that body type and that's [ __ ] up
but here's the thing also with with
married with children right now it's
different and a lot of old shows that
people like have an issue with is that
Al Bundy was an [ __ ] you know I'm
saying character like he was a dick and
he was supposed to be a bad person
that's the character or just like I
think I saw something where they did
like the finebros did this thing where
they showed new like generation like
millennials
old episodes of Seinfeld and the whole
bit was like does this does this hold up
right and everyone's like oh my god I
can't believe they're saying these
things I can't believe they're doing
these things but like once I felt
everybody was an [ __ ] too you know
I'm saying the whole funny is that I
think a lot of things get missed in
context because they don't understand
the comedy behind right or they're not
there are fans of it either or true
which is fine they don't like that
[Laughter]
as my fear yeah I mean like the whole
culture back then was so different to so
it's like the the context of the jokes
in that time is different than today's
time cuz everything is like don't see
yeah but when you watch Bad Santa he's
an [ __ ] right it all works or Always
Sunny in Philadelphia
oh yeah [ __ ] aren't terrible
and laughing at the character because
it's not really what the character says
it's like he says crazy [ __ ] because of
the carrot right but then people I think
they're just dance men they don't get it
well it's only a certain amount though I
think that the Twitter Brigade people is
a small percentage of the population I
think most people are are just are chill
it's the loud minority yeah yeah want to
get upset it's hard when they're like
constantly cuz I mean South Park still
survives and they're better than ever I
think they're even better now because
it's so taboo they should that they do
it's the reason why they're able to get
away with it is because it's an
animation like I'm not an actual like
person saying the things that they're
saying and that's cuz I forgot which
creator but like from a different
animation show they were saying like the
only way we can say these things and
write these things is because it's not
it's like a cartoon character saying and
if they're kids
yeah how how [ __ ] stupid would it be
to get angry at that but also that's why
I like when I watched when I watch The
Book of Mormon which is from the
creators of South Park and it's um it's
all the south part you know type of
humor but it's live people I was like oh
my god I can't be crazier with humans
it's a little crazier it's like oh I
can't believe they're saying these
things and those guys take a shot of
everything man they like Cartman shits
on Jews the entire show like they [ __ ]
on Mormonism all the time they [ __ ] on
Islam michela Christianity everything I
love that yeah it's the best I can't we
just [ __ ] on everything it's it's when I
hear somebody who I know has a certain
point of view [ __ ] on something that's
not their point of view I'm always like
wait a minute but you're biased yeah
yeah yeah so it's less it's less funny
because I'm like you're biased but they
[ __ ] on everything so they're not really
biased exactly mmm even though I'm sure
they have their own biases but they
don't they [ __ ] go after
everything yeah that's true I haven't
even seen them favor only thing I've
seen them only favor the Denver Broncos
they all dare Denver Broncos fans so
realtor is yeah you think that's because
the creators are or because they're in
Colorado for the show I don't know the
creators are definitely in Broncos fans
like I can I can tell you that right now
yeah we need to do an animation show
that's expensive
oh yeah at a cartoon called power house
I loved it you know so fun we did it
with maker studios our IP how much did
it cost per episode and that was Watts
iron yeah I'll tell you off-camera
anomaly ah I wrote the first season that
showed that Tim doesn't ever acknowledge
it
he brought the first season as showing
really you're they yeah doesn't seem
like he cares for the credits you never
have to see that again
I actually I just found that out like
the last time we did Jay King yeah yeah
so it was really this isn't funny at all
the first season so trash no so you just
did voice acting on it
yeah outgoing and we would go off the
script and improv a little bit but we
just go in I put it because the the
characters were mu white it's got two
white on the paper I mean they were
writing for us which is was racist no it
was me Rick and PD flow you know so it
was like it was just we would go in
there and have fun and um if ever we had
an issue with the script like I don't
like that joke we change it but they
were usually pretty great right now it's
fun it is really fun fun show they were
trying to do one with us and then I
don't know where the [ __ ] it went poo
[ __ ] huh no it's collective or
studious everyone yeah I forgot what
happened I have a killer [ __ ] cartoon
show fish but I can't say it on here why
well it's both offensive and it I don't
want anyone to steal it could put on my
damn that that could actually be
offensive enough where people are like I
like it yeah baby baby I'll say off air
are you setting any ethnic or race group
on fire oh I love the race jokes not not
not so much no oh we're gonna try to get
it trampled it oh why can't we do jokes
I feel so join us on patreon where we do
do
it's a [ __ ] crazy place to be
we're gonna do an entire episode on
adderall
coming up cool like like we're gonna
talk about at all we're gonna be on
adderall talking about that what if I
took adderall and I just became a normal
person that's the point that's the point
that'd be the fun part I never buy guys
can you stay on topic please we were at
a movie premiere the other night and
this cat next to me and Nicky he was on
adderall for sure really yeah cuz
anytime anything happened in the movie
he's like oh my god I kept getting up
and leaving yes I saw I'm like yo you
were I'm like you are so [ __ ]
annoying but yeah then then did you play
guardo like chill no he was too
entertaining any time a character did
something sad or something he would he'd
be like yeah it's like okay people yeah
exactly but that's at all emotionally
intelligent dude you don't trust me you
can read the body movement but even tip
tip was sitting like five rows up from
me and she could see this catch going
for it I usually do that outside of
adderall so does that mean you take
adderall and then you relax into it
that's why I need to see you on adderall
yeah I think you would take an accordion
and write a [ __ ] symphony out of it
haha he brush eyelids except the first
accordions of the facility would be this
thing he knows and know and then he
takes a pen and he writes the music yes
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]